here with reaction the author of the
best-selling book defeating jihad the
winnable war the make America great
again coalition chief strategist and
former deputy assistant to President
Trump Sebastian Gorka and civil rights
attorney Darryl parks I know Darrell we
were on the other side of a lot of these
these stories put aside the Trayvon
Martin case for a minute because it
didn't involve the police but the whole
narrative out of Ferguson was predicated
on a lie hands up don't shoot it didn't
happen and we know it didn't happen
because the people that testify the
eyewitnesses saw Michael Brown reach
into the car of officer Wilson trying
grab his gun and then later charged at
him and the the people that said that
were predominantly african-american
witnesses you know what why is there
this rush to judgment any time it's a
whole high profile police case obama was
was more guilty than anybody I've ever
seen well let me say to you Sean I think
this week though is not about those
these three have seen in the past this
issue today is about 500 Americans who
were shot remember when it matters these
guys don't get the presumption of
innocence Michael Darryl like in the
case of Michael Brown well but I think
in this case here though we've seen
something totally different we've seen
many people lose their lives this week
in our hearts definitely go out to all
of those families this is a town we got
to talk about assault weapons in this
country did you listen to that gunfire
we just heard on your show I mean every
time I heard here that that film footage
and hear those sounds it means we gotta
have a serious conversation in this
country about how do we address this
issue when we see people lose so many
lives so many lives we lost this week we
have to answer there must be a solution
the president has the answer to Congress
has to answer there has to be a solution
from public servants we can't stand for
this we can't stand for this that
shouldn't I just kind of know I can see
it happened and you know I today
actually happens to be I'd begin my 23rd
year now at the Fox News Channel
congratulate so many of these cases over
the years thing
nobody ever thought I'd be be here at
this point trust me when I started I've
seen so many of these cases and you know
what it happens again and again dr. Baca
it's predictable Shawn I'd like to issue
a challenge to mr. parks colin
kaepernick any democrat demagogue
anybody out there any American I want
you to show me one instance from last
Sunday in Las Vegas where an American
peace officer a police officer as the
bullets were flying stopped and said to
an African American lying on the ground
sorry I'm not going to help you I hate
you because of your skin color you'll
never find it
you'll never find one peace officer in
America who did that because what you
saw on Sunday night is what makes
America great
you saw Americans helping each other
vets nurses people who don't know
anything about combat saving each
other's lives when the stakes were the
highest possible I think your monologue
is right let's let's forget about the
politics let's forget about the NRA vs.
Hillary Clinton versus anybody else
right now let's use Las Vegas to come
together as a nation we had eight years
of divisiveness we had an administration
that looked at all of us me you the
viewers mr. parts first based upon their
skin color then their ethnic background
then their sexual preference that's on
American we don't look at each other as
categories we look at each other as
human beings as Ana's Americans I think
it's time for all of us to come together
as Americans to respect the flag to
respect the national anthem and
understand Las Vegas is the best of us I
know everyone's saying oh we can't talk
about guns I have the gun debate I have
I have a question for you so if somebody
is I know a lot of these celeb
and a lot of these politicians you know
they have their gated communities and
and these late-night host they they have
their bodyguards in their Studios and
and they're protected at the Oscars and
at the Emmys and all their self
congratulatory parties that they have on
the red carpet every year but for the
average person the only defense they
have is themselves so those people that
want gun control are talking about
abolishing the Second Amendment let me
ask you what you would do god forbid for
anybody somebody breaks into your house
Darryl parks late at night would you
rather be trained in the use of a
firearm and have that firearm available
to protect your family your wife your
kids the people you love and care about
the most
well Shana happen to be a gun owner
actually I was trained in gun safety
from the 5th grade by my boy scout troop
so a long time yes of course
of course that are saying the opposite
all week you said let's talk about guns
you know the average American doesn't
have armed bodyguards
they don't have gated compounds that
they're living in like all these
celebrities that are lecturing everybody
but but young here's the difference
though we're talking about an assault
rifle assault rifles are meant to kill
great numbers of people that's the
conversation that we have to have that's
the gorilla in the room that we have to
talk about transferring the five of your
people got shot by discuss getting any
concessions on your people they're not
they're not advocating for the NRA is
talking about getting rid of the ability
to turn this into warm a single shot
into you know a rapid fire almost
rapid-fire gun we'll give you the last
word dr. Parker Sean I learned to shoot
as soon as I could pick up a gun my
father escaped a communist dictatorship
the Second Amendment isn't about hunting
it's not even about personal
self-defense I carry a gun I'm licensed
to do so but it's about the ultimate
guarantee against a tyrannical regime it
is the ultimate guarantee
for freedom democracy and liberty that's
why every dictatorial regime from Hitler
to Mao disarmed their citizens before
they took over that's the bottom line
and that's why the Second Amendment is
non-negotiable I don't know if any of
our framers or founders ever talked
about hunting that's exactly what they
were talking about thank you both for
being with us appreciate it when we come